there is a new app called Lulu and this
is where women girls can anonymously
because we're talking about anonymity on
this show they can anonymously rate and
review their male Facebook friends as
well as men that they don't know and
again this is completely anonymously
let's look at their mission statement
Lulu is a private network for girls to
express and share their opinions openly
and honestly we created Lulu to unleash
the value of girl talk and to empower
girls to make smarter decisions on
topics ranging from relationships to
beauty and health but basically what it
is is just a ranking system of dudes you
upload the dude you answer some
questions about him and and then girls
can decide if they want to hook up with
him or have sex with a more data more
just ignore him uh so are you on there
it's my first class ah no I'm a married
woman but again that's one of those
things where I'm thinking if you're a
woman and you need an app to sit there
and choose who you're going to sleep
with or who's cool or who's not and
again who's to say that it's a woman's
only app yeah who's to say that there's
not guys on there pretending to be women
just to go on there and troll and see
what see what the girls are saying or to
make good comments about themselves I
mean right do you even know I meet so
basically I think the people that are
using this app take it with a grain of
salt that it maybe it's more
entertainment than it is am I going to
sleep with this guy does he have an STD
was he good to his ex-girlfriend right I
mean he's an ex for a reason so let's
find out what I mean it just it just
seems so stupid and kind of frivolous to
me but if college girls want this and to
check out a guy on campus and then they
think it's legitimate enough that they
can trust it and believe it wouldn't
what happens if if a guy gets a great
rating and then a girl gets raped by him
though is she gonna sue Lulu actually
you know what I mean there's so many
things that you can open up in that
Pandora's box that are not good total
it's a huge Pandora's box and the thing
is that if you liked a guy if you really
liked a guy you'd probably be with him
right so if you don't like a guy's dorm
barley
trash him on this thing cuz you don't
want to I know a little something about
girls they don't like passing off the
good guys to other girls right don't
they want the girl isn't that the whole
point gimme unlike guys who like to pass
the best girl around all the time right
uh the house movies anything and if the
guy does go rape someone I'm and it's
gonna hurt his rating the point now I
think women that I decided that's all
funny to me you know massive women you
don't need an app to get a guy you have
an app it's called the vagina yeah you
already have it called a brain it's
called meeting the guy in person
somewhere you know I mean I don't know
it just have to get women but women
don't need absa get men you have the app
right and is there something crazy to
think of that the girls would be helping
each other get good guys just seeing it
doesn't seem like the way of the world
sort of you know even if even if the
sexes were reversed but my girlfriends
and i are not i don't know maybe we're a
little bit older than this the the the
20-somethings in college now but we
would never go on a nap and be like oh
let's see what the other girls around
town are saying about the guy at the bar
I mean it's like really why what's the
point at the risk of us sounding to know
that it really is true right exactly so
at the risk of us sounding like old
fogies here at this table oh my God
we're so old compared to these kids with
their apps but is there are we losing a
little something like I've seen love
letters that my grandfather wrote to my
grandmother when he was away in the war
you mean are we losing actually some
level of romance and courtship with you
know knowing everything you can
immediately you can meet someone at a
bar on forgetting the app you can jump
on facebook and suddenly find out
everything about them or any other i
I've been in a relationship since the
Facebook was invented and so I don't
know what that's like and every once a
while I'm reminded somebody will tell me
it's like oh I met this guy I didn't
even know his last name so I couldn't
look him up on Facebook it was so
exciting to get to know him and I was
just like that is such a weird way to
date now like you already know so much
[ __ ] about someone before you ever have
sex with them like you're supposed to
have sex and not know them that's what
makes it fun that's the whole point of
sex can you imagine knowing about
someone that you're having sexual right
wouldn't have it that's what takes out
the fun right so I don't know what it's
like to date like that um did you know
what I've never been an awesome I danger
I think this really is like a
generational thing that these
Millennials or younger that they just
they just don't everything is on their
fan i watch teenage girls text each
other while they're in the same room we
feel like they'd rather text and do
these little like abbreviations and [ __ ]
then talk to one another whatever that
is I don't think I've heard of it I
don't even know what snapchat snapchat
is sorry excuse me on this happens and
nobody's net shot right okay that's a
that's an idea for an app a mustache it
already yeah but that's how you get the
guys the evolution right if you have
ever seen the like to start the chart
right of the homo sapien so it starts
off as a pavement and then now and then
you're operating now it's set out like
this I got down it's like yes you're
right it's going baby it's like people
putting TVs in their cars it's like I'd
rather look at a fictional
representation of the outside world but
actually look at the outside world
there's a world happening right as you
go by it yeah I mean that's the problem
when you see people you know it's like
the girl that the famous girl texting
she walks into the into the the
waterfall or whatever it in the mall and
then she tried to sit moms like mall
right but it's like you're so kids I
think the Millennials are so
self-centered and everything is about
them and everything is about like
instant and they want it now and they
want to communicate but not real
communication it's like this faux
communication they don't even think they
know how to have a conversation with a
man I mean so it's very disturbing I
really love to take a selfie right now
with you guys but they took my phone
away before we started the show okay